hey what's up Samuel Leeds and I am a
landlord and right now is a crazy time
to be a landlord with coronavirus they
the government have just brought in a
new emergency rule piece of legislation
that says that you cannot evict your
tenant right now for three months you
can't have it your tenants for any
reason so that means that if your tenant
does not pay rent if the tenant says I'm
not gonna pay rent this month there's
nothing you can do you have to just
accept it now whether you think that's
fair whether you think that's not fair I
could argue both ways but it doesn't
matter what I think it doesn't matter
what you think what matters is that you
have the knowledge to be able to know
what to do if you are a landlord in that
circumstance so let me just give a
little bit background to this rule and
what this emergency legislation means so
it does not mean that your tenant does
not have to pay rent that's not the rule
in fact if you go on the Citizens Advice
bureaux website as a tenant and you say
I can't pay rent because of coronavirus
what do I do
it does not say don't worry just don't
pay rent it says you have to pay your
rent
it says talk to your landlord and see if
you can work something out pay as much
as you possibly can
however if you can't you're not going to
be evicted for at least three months
it's three months before as a language
you can start court proceedings now I
get why the government are saying this
because if some people have been
affected by the coronavirus and their
suffering and their ill and they have
lost their job and they can't pay their
rent the last stress that you need when
you're having to be in the self
isolation is to be kicked out of the one
place where you can be saved that is not
cool so I understand why the government
have said that the problem is is the
government haven't really brought a
solution to the landlord because and the
reason they haven't is because the
government's perspective is hey you're
an investor you're a property investor
you know you're making lots of money you
got these investments properties
fantastic so they're not too concerned
about investors right now which which is
not cool again that's not cool because
who's gonna pay the rent if the if the
tenant doesn't pay the rent you need to
pay your mortgage you need to eat as a
landlord so who's going to pay so it's a
little bit unfair potentially whilst I
do understand it now here's a few things
that you can
so firstly is you can have a holiday
period for three months
because we're here's what that here's
what the government are saying a
government is saying the tenant and the
Landlord are in the same boat let me
read this this is what housing secretary
Robert gem Rik MP said he said the
government is clear no renter who has
lost income due to coronavirus will be
forced out of their home nor any
landlord faced unmanageable debts so
basically what they're saying is they're
saying that tenants and landlords are in
the same kind of boat but the thing that
they're not bearing in mind is that
there's a lot of landlords that we lie
not just obviously to pay their mortgage
they're relying off of the profit to
live and to eat because that's their
occupation they're a full-time landlord
and that's what the government aren't
really understanding at the moment so so
you can you can have a holiday period on
your mortgage but the holiday period on
your mortgage is going to get around the
problem of not being able to pay your
mortgage but it's not going to get
around the problem of not having any
income so so what else could you do well
another thing you could do and this is
really important is communicate with
your tenants the interesting thing is
you might be thinking as a landlord no
one's going to pay rent because I can't
evict them but actually when you read
the Citizens Advice Bureau Bureau and
you've been you start researching as if
you were a tenant not paying rent is not
really a great option because what's
gonna happen is you're not going to be
evicted for three months but then as
soon as you as soon as those three
months are up bang you're gonna have
you're gonna get evicted and people
don't want that and also generally
speaking people are protected right now
the government are paying eight up to 80
percent towards all but for all
businesses towards that their employee
salaries so most people are continuing
to be paid their salary they're working
from home they're still getting paid
they're actually not having to spend
lots of money going out on nights out
because they can't they're just at home
so most people and you might as
allowable thinking huh
my chairs not gonna pay rent but most
tenants probably are gonna pay rent
because they don't want to be evicted in
three months they don't want to fall
behind they don't want to have to leave
the property and legally they do have to
pay rent they just won't be evicted
three months if they don't so what I
would say is it as a landlord if you're
worried contact your tenants communicate
with them my wife I'm not going to take
credit my wife has been speaking to our
tenants and actually everybody's still
okay with paying rent they want to stay
in the house they don't want to be a
victim after three months so a lot of
tenants are continuing to pay rent so so
that's the first thing I'll say now
listen also if you've got money aside
and you're kind of comfortable and
you're not absolutely banking on the
income then what I'll say is don't even
worry at all because worry and fear and
panic is never gonna solve any problem
so maybe just you know relax and wait
for this due to go over because it will
however generally speaking I don't like
to tell people to relax what I'll say is
when there's a problem use it as an
opportunity to make more money elsewhere
Jim Rohn says that the same wind blows
on us all it's not the it's not the
blowing with the wind that determines
the destination it's the setting of the
sale so as Mark my advice to you is to
don't panic maybe if you need to go on
the holiday period for the for the
mortgages and I might do a whole video
about that again if you want to know
more about how that works and speak to
you tenants and it probably isn't going
to be okay
but my advice would be use these times
as an opportunity to actually start
making money as a property entrepreneur
you need to be an investor over here an
investor is someone that relies on
passive income coming again that's what
landlords do systems business is awesome
but I really strongly passionately
believed that in order to thrive through
recessions and I'm speaking from
experience because I've make money
through recessions before I got started
in 2008 and in 2008 those few years of
recession were actually where I really
really got my best deals and I really
believe that you should be an investor
and a property entrepreneur so if you're
a landlord saying oh man what do I do
maybe you need to learn to be a property
entrepreneur maybe you need to learn how
to add a deal source there's thousands
of people looking to buy properties
right now under these under these
circumstances find good deals package
them and sell them do that once once and
you've got two three thousand pounds
that month but you didn't usually
have use these times to educate yourself
use these times to be an entrepreneur
don't just sit back panic and worry
about rents not coming in so that's
generally my advice listen this whole
week even if I have to do this at home
on an iPhone in installation I'm going
to be using this time I'm gonna be
continuing to put our videos on a daily
basis they're going to be tailored
towards these current circumstances
these current times so what if I can
help in any way if I can help you as an
entrepreneur I can have you as a
landlord with information let me know
what you want to know comment below and
let me know what you want to learn about
what you want me to talk about are we
talking about the holiday mortgage
periods and what that means and how you
can potentially apply for that I'm going
to be talking about generally some of
the crazy things that happening with the
coronavirus and what the government was
saying I'll be talking about deals
sourcing I'm going to be talking about
serviced accommodation units and if
you've got rent to serviced
accommodations what to do and how to
protect yourself and protect your income
so these are some of the things I'm
planning on talking about but comment
below share this video if you know
people are in property that are
landlords or people that are looking to
get into property share this video
because this message needs to be known
people need to know how to protect
themselves they need to know what their
rights are as a landlord what the
tenants rights are so guys I'm going to
keep putting that content thank you so
much for watching this video please do
smash the like button if you're not
subscribe at there's no better time
subscribe but now because this channel
is about to get very very interesting in
these times thank you so much peace out
I'll see you next I'll see you tomorrow
sue come on